this overnight ferry was packed with up
to 800 people heading out of dhaka for a
weekend away with friends and family
many would have been sleeping in these
crowded cabins as the fire took hold in
the engine room
the engine had been running for about an
hour while on fire
later the fire probably spread from the
engine to the oil tank and they stopped
the loud bang at this spot where we are
standing right now
as flames whipped through the ferry many
passengers jumped into the river to
escape according to police they believe
the engine carried on running for an
hour as the fire took hold
many survivors have suffered terrible
burn injuries and the death toll is
expected to rise
i was on the second floor
suddenly the engine exploded and caught
fire it had been malfunctioning from
earlier on but the negligence of the
ferry authority resulted in the fire the
ferry was covered in curtains all the
heat from the explosion was trapped
inside and that he'd made everything
firm
dozens of bodies have been recovered so
far ferry accidents are common in
bangladesh usually blamed on
overcrowding and lacks enforcement of
rules
ferries are a main means of transport in
a country that's crisscrossed by more
than 130 rivers
the government has set up two committees
to investigate the fire they've been
ordered to report their findings in
three days
bernard smith al jazeera